المترجم: Basant Amro
المدقّق: Riyad Almubarak
أعتقد أن أغلبنا هنا تربى على مقولة مهمة
جدّاً لتوصيف النجاح
قيلت له في البيت، وهي: "ادرس تنجح، ادرس
أكثر لتحصل على درجات."
العملية قريبة من فكرة أنك كلما ابتعدت أكثر
كلما زادت فرصتك بالنجاح.
الفكرة هي أنه لدي بعض الاعتراضات
على هذه المقولة، وربما أنتم أيضاً.
فكِّر في لحظة من اللحظات التي قلت فيها:
"درست لهذه المادة كثيراً،
لا أعلم كيف حصلت على هذه الدرجة."
أو : "مع أنني أكثر موظف ملتزم في المكتب
ولكن وقت الترقية، يرقي مديري شخصاً غيري."
بدأت بعض الأمور التي تقابلكم تضع فيكم نقاط
الشك حول هذه المقولة، لماذا؟
لأن المقولة كمية.
تقول أن كل الجهود محمودة
الحقيقة هي أن ليس كل الجهود محمودة.
هناك الكثير من الجهود المهدرة.
وربما ارتبط بفكرتنا عن النجاح حلمٌ
من أحلام اليقظة
الحلم هذا كان عن النجاح المبكِّر
أن النجاح ينتظرك على عتبة
شيء جديدٍ تبدأ به
بمعنى، عندما أدخل الجامعة
عند بداية دخولي الجامعة عند أول عمل
لي سيفاجئ الناس بجودة العمل الذي أقدمه
وسيقولون "واو" كيف فعل ذلك؟
أو سأسافر إلى خارج بلدي، لو سافرت
سأكون من أنجح الناس
لو عملت في هذه الشركة، سأكون رئيسها
فكرة النجاح المبكر.
وقد يلخص الأمر حلم الكثير من الناس
قد مروا به "حلم تجارب الأداء"
أنك تدخل تجارب الأداء حيث يكون الموجودون
مقللين من إمكانياتك.
ثم تبدأ بالغناء أو بعمل أي شيء
فيبدأ الناس الموجودون بالوقوف وتهنئتك.
ولو تلاحظ أن هذه الفكرة مرتبطة
بوجود من يهنئك.
ركز الفكرة في الأساس مبنية على احتياجك
لهذه النقطة.
وليست مبنية على رغبتك في النجاح.
وعادة ما كنت تأخذ هذه الفكرة وتبدأ
تتفاعل معها
المشكلة أن الأثر للنجاح المبكر
قد يصبح "مصيبة"
قد يصبح أكثر شيء لا تريده في حياتك.
دعوني أخبركم عن تجربة مررت بها شخصيًا.
أنا أدرس وكنت أدرس مادة اسمها التصميم
للذين لا يعرفون التصميم هي مادة تحمل
الكثير من فكرة التوفيق في الحياة.
معيار التقيم فيها مختلف جدا بمعنى
ليس كلما أكثرت جهدك في التصميم
كلما أخذت درجات عالية أو سيكون
تصميمك الأفضل
وليس كل التصاميم عليها اتفاق أي أنه
بعض التصاميم يراها الناس تصاميم إبداعية
وناس أخرى ترى نفس التصاميم بشكل عادي
ومشكلة طلاب التصميم إن المشهور والمتفوق
في التصميم يكون لهم كوكب مثل كوكب المشاهير
ماذا يعني ذلك؟
دائما في المشروع الذي يليه يبدأوا يتتبعوا
كم حصل فلان من درجة على هذا المشروع
وتبدأ بعض الإشاعات بالظهور
تغذي غرور المصممين
فدراسة التصميم كنوع من أنواع الفن
تمر بمراحل مختلفة عن أي شيء آخر
المهم، كنت في السنة الأولى وأخذت مشروع
والمشروع كان المشروع الأساسي
لسنة الأولى، وكنت من الأوائل
وبالتالي وضع اسمي في القائمة التي يبحث
عنها الأشخاص كل فترة.
انتهت السنة الأولى بدأنا السنة الثانية
يوجد كادر جديد يجب علي أن أثبت قدراتي
لأن الإنطباعات الأولى تدوم.
يوجد كادر جديد
يوجد أساتذه جدد ويجب أن أكمل
سلسلة نجاحي.
السلسلة التي تقول بأن النجاح دائما سيستمر
وأخذت بالأسباب، بمعنى
بدأ يطلب مننا تصميم، جلست على نفس الكرسي
جلست على نفس المكتب
أمسكت بالقلم كما أمسكه كل مرة
اخترت نفس نوع الورق الذي أعمل به
نفس المدرسة الفكرية وبدأت الرسم
انتهيت بثقة تماما، انتظرت النتيجة.
النتيجة تكون بالدرجات A+
A, A- الاسم لم يظهر بعد
ـ B+, B, B
عندما وصلت لهذه المرحلة
واسمي لم يظهر من كثر ثقتي في ما قدمته
أخبرت نفسي أن مشروعي لم يصحح
أكيد لم يصحح
لم أفق إلا عندما نادوا على اسمي في خانة F
كيف F؟
كل ما تملكني بعدها غضب وعدم قدرة
على التفسير أنا لم أحاول التفسير
كل ما كنت أفكر به كيف يعطوني درجة F
هل يعلمون من أنا؟ بالطبع أنا لست مثل
أي شخص أنا الطالب المميز لسنة الأولى
ألا تعلمون من أنا؟
وزملاؤك مصدومين لكن
كل ما تفكر به الآن سترون ما سأفعل
كيف ستريهم لا تعلم، لكن الفكرة فقط
هي أنا سأريكم
حسنا كيف ستريهم، جاء المشروع الثاني
عدلت جلستي قليلا أمسكت بالقلم وشددت عليه
وجلست مدة أطول وسهرت فيه فقالوا
هذا المشروع الوحيد الذي حصل على اثنين A+
(ضحك)
قالو A+ لم يكن اسمي موجود
قالو B+ لم يكن اسمي فيه B, B-
لم يكن اسمي موجود
أصبت بالقلق. اكتشفت أن مشروعي
حصل على مقبول
عندها فقدت المنطق
أنا لا أفهم مقبول كيف ولماذا أنا لا أعلم
من أكلم ماذا سأقول الذين حولي
بدأوا يبتعدون ويذهبون إلى أماكن أخرى.
المشروع الذي يليه بدأت مرحلة الإنكار أكيد
لست أنا من أخطأ أكيد يوجد شيء في النظام
أغير طريقة جلستي أفعل هكذا
أبدأ مرة أخرى لا يوجد
ماذا أفعل؟
مجموعة من الجهود المهدرة تماما
المجهود كثير لكن مهدر.
إلى أن أكرمني الله في مشروع ما
شخص جلس معي جلسة مختلفة
وبدأ يخبرني بطريقة التصميم بشكل مختلف
أنا في هذه المرحلة كنت مجروح ككرامة
دخلت المشروع بطريقة مختلفة تماما.
بكرسي مختلف وقلم مختلف ووضع
مختلف ومدرسة فكرية مختلفة.
وظهرت النتيجة F
(ضحك)
أنا أصبحت في قاع الأرض.
لا يوجد شيء اخر أخسره
والمشكلة الكبرى أنك تبدأ في التفسير لأهلك
تبدأ تبرر لماذا حصلت على هذه الدرجة.
أنت لم تدرس هذا أكيد لا يوجد مزاح
لو كنت درست كنت نجحت
لو درست كثيرا كنت أصبحت من المتفوقين
انتهى لم يعد هناك شيء لأخسره
بدأت أفكر لنفسي بدأت أفكر
لإرضاء نفسي
الخطوات التي وضعتها لاحقا
لا أعرف من الذي أوحى لي بها
لكن هذه هي المرة الأولى التي أصبحت
أركز فيها بدون أن اثبت لأي شخص أي شيء
وأنا أعمل على المشروع وقف أستاذ المادة
إلى جانبي وقال لي هذا المشروع جميل جدا
أصبحت أنظر اليه اتدرك
كم انتظرت هذه الكلمة!
هل تتخيل أنني من بداية السنة 6 شهور
إلى الآن كنت أنتظر كلمة مثل هذه،
لكن الغريب أن أثرها في نفسي
لم يكن عاليا بصراحة لم يعد يهمني
لم أشعر بالنصر.
وعندما ظهرت النتيجة كنت من الأوائل
لكن خلال الفترة اللاحقة الدرجة ما زالت
أتذكرها الدرجة التي أخذتها في هذا المشروع
لم أخذ أقل منها لاحقا، بسبب أو بآخر الشخص
الذي كان يترجم هذا الموضوع للفشل أصبح يدرس
لا أعلم لماذا لكن في نقطة أساسية ما
أدركت أنه يوجدة حفرة
وهذه الحفرة يمر بها الكثير
من الطلاب لدينا.
فكانت الفكرة كيف أبدء شرح هذا لهم؟
مرحلة هل تتجه إلى الهوية
أو تتحدث أو ماذا تفعل لم أفهم
فبدأت فكرة (نظرية الرز) ما هي نظرية الأرز؟
أنا أحب الخبز وأحب الطبخ والقريب مني
يعلم ذلك
أعتقد أن الخبز أو الطبخ نوع من أنواع الفن
رغم أني أحب هذه الأشياء
وأعمل على الوصفات المعقدة
لكني أتجنب الأرز جدا
الذي هو من المفترض أنه عند بعض
الناس شيء يطبخ بشكل تلقائي
عند أمي أنا يطبخ بشكل تلقائي
ودعوني أوضح أمر معين الذي
سأتحدث عنه الآن لا ينطبق على أمي
لماذا؟ لأن الفكرة عند الأمهات...
تعرفون جرس الميكرويف
جرس الميكرويف هذا يكون عند الأم
أول ما تبدأ بوضع الأرز وتبدأ بوضع الماء
وفجأة تتوقف ثم تضعه على النار
فيطهى الأرز.
فالذي سأقوله الآن قد يكون صادما
لكن هذا لا ينطبق عليهم
هذا ينطبق على الذين من أمثالنا
فكرة الأرز هو أنه يوجد أكثر من نوع للأرز
يوجد طويل التيلة، يوجد الأرز المصري،
يوجد الأرز الإيطالي، يوجد الكثير منهم
كل نوع منهم له خاصية
الخاصية هي مقدار الماء التي يشربها الأرز
بمعنى لكي يطهى الأرز البسمتي
له مقدار من الماء ولكي أطهي
الأرز الطويل له مقدار
والبسمتي أو الطويل على حسب المصنع
تختلف جودة الأرز فيختلف مقدار الماء
فلا يوجد له شيء مطلق.
فسنأخذ حالة خيالية،
وتتخيل معي طلب منك أن تطهو الأرز
فأتيت أنت وجلبت الأرز ووضعت الماء
على الأرز "ابراكدبرا" طهي الأرز
فجاءة الأرز طهي بشكل رائع أتى زمالاؤك
ما هذا ما هذه الروعة أنت تطهو أفضل من أمي
أنت تطهوه أفضل من زوجتي
تعالوا انظروا فلان طهى الأرز
جاء أناس وراءه ما هذا يا شيف!
مع أثر الذين دخلوا وبدأوا بالتهنئة فعلا
توقعت أنه أنا الشيف جاءت المرة التالية لطهيه
أخذت المعاير التي لا تعلمها في الأساس
ووضعتها "ابراكدبرا"
أتى زملاؤك للتذوق يوجد مشكلة
الأرز ليس جيدا
ابتدؤوا هو يحتاج كذا كيف
بدأت بالبتذوق يا جماعة
لا لا يوجد خطأ، أنت لا تراجع أو
تحلل المشكلة أنت تبدأ مرحلة المكابرة
انتظرو في المرا التالية "ابراكدبرا"
أكبر قليلا والعملية بدأت تفشل
الناس تنسحب وأنت تقنعهم
انتظروا انتظروا أنا من طهيت الأرز
أليس أنتم من قلتم أنني افضل من ...
تعالوا أنا سأطهوا إن آجلا أم عاجلا
وفجأة بدؤوا ينسحبوا من حولك
وفجأة أنت على غير هدى تبذل مجهود
لكن جميع هذه الجهود كانت مهدرة
نتفق
شخص أخر هو وليس أنت
الشخص الاخر طلب منه طهو الأرز
ووضع الأرز و الماء ووضعهم على النار
أصبح الأرز مطهو زيادة عن اللزوم
أتعلمون كيف أصبح الأرز كالماء
إذا ما هي المشكلة ضعونا نقلل
نسبة الماء قلل نسبة الماء اصبح الأرز جاف
حلل هذا وذاك أصبح يعاير بالنصف
الأرز بدا يصبح جيد
هذا الشخص أصبح يبذل بعض المجهود
بالنسبة إلى الشخص الأول
الذي بذل جهود مهدرة
لكن عندما بدأ في التعديل في ثالث محاولة
وهو يطهو الأرز ما الذي حدث
أو في رابع أو خامس محاولة
طهى الأرز بشكل صحيح ومن بعدها
لا يطهوه بشكل خاطئ أو بشكل كبير
هذا الشيف
فأنت أمامك شيء من اثنين إما أن تعتبر
نجاحك تحدي يجب أن تثبته للناس خذ راحتك
عذرا " اخبط راسك" عاند
أو تعرف أن التحدي المطلوب
هو أن تثبت لنفسك النجاح
لا أحد يطلب منك ليس من المفترض
أن تثبت لأي شخص أي شيء هو الأساس
اثنين قلل من بكائك على ذاتك قليلا
لو قللت من بكائك على ذاتك
ولو كان أضرك كثيرا من الناس
الذين شاهدوك وأنت تخفق فصدقني البشر
أبسط من هذا
فاليوم الذي تنجح معك الوصفة وتستمر لحظتها
لن يتذكروا إلا شيء واحد أنك كنت الشيف
شكرا
(تصفيق)